سالنا الناس في الاردن ما الذي يستهلك
اكبر جزء من راتبك الشهري نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اكثر
رواتب يروح على الكهرباء وعلى الميه اكثر
اشي وعلى المدارس مصروف المدارس والكهرباء
من الراتب بروح على ايجار البيت يعني
فعليا المواطن الاردني المستاجر يحتاج الى
راتبين اللي هم راتب يكون ايجار يصرف على
حاله اما اللي عايش على راتب واحد وبيته
اجار فعليا دائما ملحوق ومقضيها دين بدين
على اقساط الجامعه الدراسه بشكل عام يعني
والاشياء الثانيه هي مصاريف اي بلاد
مصرفها طبيعي
والله اكبر جزء من راتبي بروح على اجره
البيت والكهرباء والماء والمواصلات هسه
يعني على وضع البلد الاقتصادي حاليا اكبر
جزء بيروح اكيد لاجار البيت يعني بالنسبه
للوضع اللي بنعيشه بالبلد اللي هي
الكهرباء بتاخد اكثر صنف يعني خلينا نحكي
وايجار البيت
[موسيقى]